if this was Pearl's World I'd get rid of
birth control I'd ban it but that'll
never happen
I think that was the root of all evil
and I'd actually go for the root of all
evil the root of all evil that's what
she said okay my girl
say it I I don't know I don't think
women should know
[Music]
women you can't vote no birth control
keep it going because it's always
freedom without responsibility so like
the remix should not be no pearly said
it hurts I'll tell you why though I'll
tell you why because there's freedom
without responsibility and before women
like the the like I believe in
consequences for your decision so the
men know if they vote someone batshit
crazy into Power you guys get drafted we
don't women decide elections where 55 of
the population I think if we want to
vote equally draft us you don't want
equality and personally I don't want to
get drafted so I'll be in the kitchen
foreign
I thought she was crazy
I think she has a point
go ahead
she's talking about equality sure
that's just what the birth control thing
hey yo but I understand where she coming
from with the uh drafting thing two
hours later no it's not because they
don't it's not because they vote and
they don't get drafted that they don't
suffer the consequences of not being
with nah so yeah no I got nothing I
really tried
why don't you just say women should get
drafted this whole idea of like you
shouldn't get voted to get drafted first
off when's the last time the draft
happened
but what 30 40 50 years okay that's one
two
you act like when people get elected to
be politicians they don't knock laws
that negatively impact strictly women
what you think a birth control ban
wouldn't affect women primarily
no it's not just men what do you think
an abortion ban doesn't affect women
primarily
right there are plenty laws that a crazy
badship politician come in and enact
that would primarily only affect women
but you pulled up drafts which is like
something that rarely if ever happens
and then you're just using that to say
they should lose their right to vote
and the birth control thing was so crazy
to me
it's like argument for the birth control
I guess is because of birth control
women can now be more selective and so
it's worse for society so they want to
remove your ability to choose and here's
a problem okay
this girl is a really popular red pill
Creator and people sent me this link
because the dude in the interview was
acting [ __ ] and to be fair in the
interview she was waking a lot more sins
than that guy was okay but I I stopped
at this part and I had to cringe so
incredibly [ __ ] hard because I don't
think people realize how crazy red pill
folks sound when they say stuff like
this and how easy it describes them uh
to vote and I think also they should
lose their right to some of the biggest
invention that brought us to this
current age right now people want to
just get rid of because what a lot of
these folks enter this red pill space
and they'll say like oh we're not
misogynist we're not misogynist we're
not anti-weather not type of you should
lose your right to vote and you should
lose your ability to have contraceptives
what you cannot hold on to the moniker
that you guys are not misogynist that
you guys are not anti-women and then
take away some of the most basic
fundamental rights to people who not
only pay taxes who not only participate
in society as full-fledged adults and
have to finance things you know like
listen whether you like it or not women
are paying their taxes women are
involved in politics women are helping
to make these decisions they're in
managerial positions it's not like
they're here on the side that's not the
case and I also 51 of the planet okay so
you sit there you say we're not massages
but people who contribute a lot to
society should have the right to vote is
crazy because I imagine if you're really
looking at it like well they don't
contribute as much as a man there's
plenty of groups who don't contribute as
much as others should they lose their
right to participate in democracy what
about poor people only risk people to
vote because they pay the most amount of
taxes that how it should be huh that
makes sense old folks women
kids because if you can you know if
you're like 12 you can hold a rifle
I mean you haven't contributed to
society yet
you could make that case oh you don't
vote you go to war and the rest fund
yeah it's not that bad think about it I
think it makes sense there you go it's
just this is the kind of stuff that you
will see that will come and discredit
the red pill folks and I'm saying this
as like
forget me let's say a news person pulls
up a media hit piece okay on Redfield
folks they're gonna play this clip this
is Pearl's World I'd get rid of birth
control I'd ban it I think that's the
root of all evil
and Their audience gonna know that red
pill popular people are saying dumb [ __ ]
like this and it's gonna discredit
everything this is not like a uh a wacky
take like oh you know like I feel like
women should earn more than men or men
should earn more than it's not that you
should learn lose your ability to vote
now you may not care about voting but
understand it is one of the most
fundamental freedoms that we have in the
Free World okay you may not care for it
but it is one of the most important it's
akin to telling people you should lose
Free Speech because you're a woman
that's how crazy it is and if you don't
understand I'll unhinged this messaging
is I don't think people are really
listening to what it means to the
average person it's interesting because
I'll say like red pill stains for the
truth uh people are misunderstanding the
red pill the red pill is not misogyny it
states for the truth women shouldn't be
able to vote [ __ ] you are bugging you
are bucking play this clip to 99 of
people and they'll be like you are
bucking yes but peep game
in their way of thinking
that's the truth
that woman
do a whole bunch of crazy things without
any repercussion they just do [ __ ] it's
wild and if they do [ __ ] in this world
and they vote and then swap to them
that's the truth and that's why they
call it the truth yeah still misogyny
yes you can't say this is the truth it's
not misogyny but it's like your truth is
misogyny but it's like I don't like
using that word because it's so overused
it makes me cringe it's like let's be
honest if somebody comes out and say
women shouldn't be able to vote for this
reason yeah uh you're gonna be painted
as misogynist yes it's exactly like
whenever people
they're they're they're they're they're
Ultra conception of what being a Ross's
is
is the dude with a little mustache if
you don't
sure if you're not that then you're not
you're not that even though you you use
certain things so people for them to be
a misogynist you have to delete people
or having the intention of deleting
people or not wanting to have the
intentions in that and because they're
not that extreme they don't want to be
painted as that true I think that's why
this is happening and he said I'm not
I'm not that I mean I love them you are
I look I love women you gotta wear that
hat you got to wear that hat that's
that's what you guys are and not all of
you but the folks who endorse in this
kind of rhetoric yeah that's what you
want everyone but you say a lot of stuff
listen there's stuff that these red
pills say that is absolutely true you
know when they're talking about
hypergamy and the idea that like you
know there's some discriminatory
practices that women engage in that are
absolutely hypocritical and then they
demand to be coddled all the time about
their preferences or whatever it's like
yeah no no no no no no throw out some
[ __ ] and we pointed out but I would
never want to associate with the label
because of crunch [ __ ] like this right
oh red pill is the truth yes and
feminine feminism stands for equality
but 99 of you [ __ ] don't want to be
called yourselves famous okay for a
reason
because you understand that even though
at its root it may be that you
understand the way it manifests in the
world and the way that it's marketed
isn't that same thing with retro it's
like I can buy into a lot of the truth
things that they say but guess what you
guys are so [ __ ] cringe online it
takes so much radical dumb [ __ ] that I'm
like I would never want to associate
with that kind of branding
ever listen to that
and if you don't understand how crazy
that sounds again play that clip for
most people in the world and look like
uh this [ __ ] is crazy
and it's unfortunate because you could
have a bunch of great takes right like
her in this podcast she did a great job
for the most part countering what a Visa
say because her fees was lost but
if you do all of this and then in the
middle of your Spiel you're like let's
bring back slavery sorry you're gonna
lose a lot of people you know what I
mean like you're gonna lose a lot of
people so you guys got to understand the
way some of this stuff is perceived
online I know folks want me to react to
me but I thought this was a flash point
for me because outside of this red pill
space the only thing that a regular
person is going to care about when they
watch this interview is the portion
where she's saying that's her solution
to a lot of problems women need to go to
wife school they need to lose birth
control if they lose their right to vote
if that's being so why are you on that
podcast who's me that girl should be
talking right now she's a woman
shut the [ __ ] up lady
you're a woman right start with you [ __ ]
don't vote go to the kitchen shut the
[ __ ] up we don't want to hear you that
[ __ ] was crazy bro whenever you say
something like that well there's a
percussion and there's you know
consequences yeah if you don't decide to
you know take account
no I think viewers are smart viewers
understand to take what they can and
then leave away what they don't like you
think yeah I think I think a lot of
people probably would see this clip even
folks who call themselves a red pill or
whatever it is and they look at this and
like nah I'm not rocking with that and I
think that's good so I think the viewers
you know got to give them some credit
most of them can find and figure this
[ __ ] out uh but yeah that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
makes y'all look bad that [ __ ] makes all
look bad so just careful who you
Champion out here because they can
easily come to discredit your movement
let us know what you guys think maybe
you guys agree or disagree we want to
hear from you